alright last time I started talking
about linearize ability and I want to
finish up this time the reason why we're
talking about it again is that it's our
kind of standard definition for what
strong consistency means in storage
style systems so for example lab 3 is a
needs to obey your lab 3 needs to be
linearizable and sometimes this will
come up because we're talking about a
strongly consistent system and we're
wondering whether a particular behavior
is acceptable and other times linearize
ability will become come up because
we'll be talking about a system that
isn't linearizable and we'll be
wondering you know in what ways might it
fall short or deviate from linearize
ability so one thing you need to be able
to do is look at a particular sequence
of operations a particular execution of
some system that executes reads and
writes like your lab 3 and be able to
answer the question oh was that was that
Stevens of operations I just saw
linearizable or not I'm so we're going
to continue practicing that a little bit
now plus I'll try to actually establish
some interesting facts that will be
helpful for us about what it means about
the consequences for the systems we
build and look at linearize ability is
to find on particular operation history
so always the thing we're talking about
is oh we observed you know a sequence of
requests by clients and then they got
some responses at different times and
they asked for different different you
know to read different data and got
various answers back you know is that
history that we saw linearizable ok so
here's an example of a history that
might or might not be linearized able so
let's suppose at some point in time some
client groups of times gonna move to the
right this vertical bar marks the time
at which a client sent a request I'm
gonna use this notation to mean that the
request is a write and asks to set
variable or key or whatever x2 value 0
so sort of a key and a value this would
correspond to a put of key X and by zero
in lab 3 and then this is sort of we're
watching what the client send the client
sent this request to our service and at
some point the service responded and
said yes you're right is completed so
we're assuming the services of a nature
that actually tells you when the write
completes otherwise the definition isn't
very useful ok so we have this request
by somebody to write and then I'm
imagining in this example there's
another request that because I'm putting
this mark here this means the second
request started after the first request
finished and and you know reason why
that's important is because of this rule
that linearizable history must match
real time and what that really means is
that requests that are known in real
time to have started after some other
request finished the second request has
to occur after the first request in
whatever order we work out that's the
proof that the history was a linearized
linearize available ok so in this
example I'm imagining there's another
request that asks to write X to have
value 1 and then a concurrent request
may be started a little bit later as to
set X to 2 I said now we have two maybe
two different clients issued requests at
about the same time to set X to two
different values so of course we're
wondering which one is going to be the
real value and then we also have some
reads if all you have is writes well
well you have us right so it's it's hard
to say too much about linearizable
linearize ability because you don't know
you don't have any proof that the system
actually did anything or revealed any
values so we really need reads so let's
imagine we have some read unless you'll
be seeing our in the history
that a client said to read at this time
and the second time it got an answer for
red key accent got value to so
presumably actually saw this value and
then there was another request by maybe
the same client or a different client
but known to have started in time after
this request finished and this read of X
got value while and so the question in
front of us is is this history
linearizable and there's sort of two
strategies we can take we can either
cook up a sequence because if we can
come up with a total order of these five
operations that obeys real time and in
which each read sees the value written
by the priest most recently proceeding
right in the order if we can come up
with that order then that's a proof the
history is linearizable another strategy
is to observe that these rules each one
may imply certain this comes before that
edges in a graph and if we can find a
cycle in this operation must come before
that operation we can find a psych on
that graph and that's proof that the
history isn't linearizable and for small
histories we may actually be able to
enumerate every single order and use
that show this history isn't
linearizable anyway any any any thoughts
about whether this might be or might not
be linearizable
yes
yes okay so the observation is that um
it's a little bit troubling that we saw
read with IU - and then the read with
value want and maybe that contradicts
you know there were two rights one with
value one on one value - so that so we
certainly if we had to read with value
three that would obviously be something
I got terribly wrong you know but we got
there were a right of one in two and a
read of one and two so the question is
whether this order of reads could
possibly be reconciled with the way
these two rights show up in the history
okay so what I'm what I'm the game we're
playing is that we have a like maybe two
clients or three clients and they're
talking some service you know maybe a
raft last year something and what we are
seeing is requests and responses right
so what this means is that we saw
requests from a client to write X to the
you know put requests for X and one and
we saw the response here so what we know
is that somewhere during this interval
of time presumably the service actually
internally change the value of x - 1 and
what this means is that somewhere in
this interval of time the service
presumably changed its internal idea of
the value of x - 2 somewhere in this
time but you know it's just somewhere in
this time it doesn't mean it happened
here or here does that answer your
question
yes
yes okay so the observation is that is
linearizable and it's been accompanied
by an actual proof of the linearize
ability namely a demonstration of the
order that shows that it is linearizable
and the order is yes it's linearizable
and the order is first right of X with
value 0 and the server got both of these
rights at roughly the same time it's
still had to choose the order itself all
right so let's just say it could have
executed the right of x2 value 2 first
and then the read of X then executed the
read of X which would the first read of
X which at that point would yield 2 and
then we're gonna say the next operation
had executed it was the right of X to 1
and then the last operation in the
history is the read of X to 1 and so
this is proof that the history is
linearizable because here's an order
it's a total order of the operations and
this is the order it matches real time
so what that means is well just go
through it the the right of X to 0 comes
first and that's that's totally
intuitive since it's actually finished
before any other operations started the
right of X to 1 comes sorry the rate of
X to 2 comes second so we're gonna say
maybe that I'm gonna mark here that sort
of real time at which we imagine these
operations happen to demonstrate that
the order here does match real time so
it'll say I'll just write a big X here
to mark the time when we imagine this
operation happened all right so that's
the second operation then we're
imagining that the next operation is the
read of X of 2 we you know there's no
real time problem because the read of X
of 2 actually was this u concurrently
with the right of X of 2 you know it's
not like the right of X the read of X of
2 finished and only then did the right
of X right of X with to start there
really are concurrent we'll just imagine
that that
sort of point in time at which this
operation happened is right there so
this is the you know we don't care when
this one happened let's just say there's
the first operation second third now we
have a right of X of one let's just say
it happens here in real time just has to
happen after the operations that occur
before it in the order so that will say
there's the fourth operation and now we
have the read of x1 and it can pretty
much happen at any time but let's say it
happens here okay so this is the
Diamonds
so we have the order this is the
demonstration that the order is
consistent with real time that is we can
pick a time for each of the operations
that's within its start and end time
that would cause this total order to
match our real time order and so the
final question is did each read see the
value written by the most closely
preceding right of the same variable so
there's two V's this read preceded by a
right with that correct value so that's
good and this read is preceded by a
right most closely preceded by a right
of the same value also okay so this this
is a demonstration that this history was
linearizable and you know the you know
depends on what you thought when you
first saw the history but it's not
always immediately clear that set up
this complicated is you know it's easy
to be tricked when looking at these
histories which do you think oh the
right of x1 started first so we just
sort of assumed that the first value
written must be one but that's actually
not required here any questions about
this
if the you mean if these two were moved
like this the okay so if if if this if
the right with value to was only issued
by the client after the read of accent
value to returned that wouldn't be
linearizable because in whatever order
you know any order we come up with has
to obey the real-time ordering so any
order we come up with would have had to
have the read of X with to precede the
right of X with 2 and since there's no
other right of X of 2 insight here that
means that a read at this point could
only see 0 or 1 because those are the
only other 2 rights that could possibly
come before this read so moving you know
shifting these that much makes the would
make the example not linearizable
yes
I'm saying that the first vertical line
is the moment the client sends the
request and the second vertical line is
the moment the client receives the
request yes yeah yeah so this is a very
client centric kind of definition it
says you know clients should see the
following behavior and what happens
after us send a request in maybe there's
a lot of replicas maybe a complicated
network who knows what it's almost none
of our business we're only the
definition is only about what clients
see there's some gray areas which we'll
come to in a moment like if the client
should need to retransmit a request then
we also have to you know that's
something we have to think about okay so
this one is linearizable here's another
example I'm actually going to start out
with it being almost identical I'm gonna
start out with you being identical for
the first example so again we have a
right of X with 0 we have these two
concurrent rights and we have the same
two reads those are so far identical to
the previous example so therefore we
know this must be this alone must be
minimal but I'm going to add let's let's
imagine that client 1 issued these two
requests the definition doesn't really
care about clients but her own sanity
will assume client 1 red X and saw two
and then later red X and saw one but
that's okay so far I say there's another
client and the other client does a read
of X and it sees a 1 and then the other
client is a second read of X and it sees
- so this is linearizable and we either
have to come up with an order
or this comes before that graph that has
a cycle in it
so you know that thing this is getting
at the puzzle is if one client saw
there's only two rights here so they you
know in any order or one of the rights
comes first or the other rate comes
first and intuitively client one
observed that the right with value to
came first and then the right of value
one right these two reads mean that has
to be the case that in any legal order
of the right of two has to come before
the right of one in order for the climb
when to have seen this and it's the same
order we saw over here but symmetrically
client one's experience clearly shows
the opposite right sorry huh fine to
client who's experience was the opposite
clients to saw the right of one first
and then the right with value too and
one of the rules here is that there's
just one total order of operations not
allowed to have different clients see
different histories or different
different progressions evolutions of the
values that are stored in the system
there can only be one total of order
that all clients have to experience
operations that are consistent with the
one order and if one this one client
clearly implies that the order is right
- and then right one and so we should
not be able to have any other client who
observes proof that the order was
anything else which is what we have here
and so that's a bit of a intuitive
explanation for what's going wrong here
and and by the way the reason why this
could come up in the systems that we
build and look at is that we're building
replicated systems either you know raft
replicas or maybe systems with caching
in them but we're building systems that
have many copies of the data and so
there may be many servers with copies of
X in them possibly with different values
at different times right if they haven't
gotten the commits yet or something some
replicas may have one value some may of
the other
but in spite of that if our system is
linearizable or strongly consistent it
must behave as if there was only one
copy of the data and one linear sequence
of operations applied to the data that's
why this is an interesting example
because this could come up in a sort of
buggy system that had two copies of the
data and one copy executed these rights
in one order and the other replicas
executed the rights in the other order
and then we could see this and linearize
ability says no we can't see that we're
not allowed to see that in the correct
system so the the cycle in the graph in
the this comes before that graph that
would be a sort of slightly more proof e
proof that this is not linearizable is
that the right of two has to come before
client ones read of two so there's one
arrow like this so this right has to
come before that read client ones read
has to come before the right of X with
value one otherwise this read wouldn't
be able to see one right if this you can
imagine this right might happen very
early in the order but in that case this
read of X wouldn't see one it would see
two since we know this guy saw two so
the read of X with two must come before
the right of X with one the right of X
of one must come before any read of X
with value 1 because including client
who's read of X with value 1 but in
order to get value 1 here and for this
read to see to the right of X with I too
must come between in in the order
between these two operations so we know
that the read of X 1 must come before
the right of X 2 and that's a cycle
alright so there's no there's no Vinnie
or order or that but there's no linear
order that can obey all of these time
and value rules and there isn't because
there's a cycle in the
in the graph yes
that's a good question this this
definitions the definition about
history's not about necessarily systems
so what it's not saying is that a system
design is linearizable if something
about the design it's really only
history by history so if we don't get to
know how the system operates internally
and the only thing we know is we get to
watch it while it executes then before
we've seen anything we just don't know
right we mean we'll assume it's
linearizable and then we see more and
more sequences of operations this Akash
they're all consistent with linearize
ability they all follow these rules so
you know we believe it's probably this
isn't linearize of all and if we ever
seen one that isn't then we realize it's
not linearizable so this is yeah it's
not a definition on the system design
it's a definition on what the what we
observe the system to do so in that
sense it's maybe a little bit
unsatisfying if you're trying to design
something right there's not a recipe for
how you design you know except in a
trivial sense that if you had a single
server in very simple systems one server
one copy of the data not threaded or
multi-core or anything it's a little bit
hard to build a system that violates
this in a very simple set up but super
easy to violate it in any kind of
distributed system okay so the lesson
from this is that there's only can only
be one order in which the system is
observed to execute the writes all
clients have to see value is consistent
with the system executing the writes in
the same order
here's a very simple history
another example supposing we write acts
with value 1 and then definitely
subsequently in time maybe with another
client another client launches a right
of X with value 2 and sees a response
back from the service saying yes I did
the right and then a third client does a
read of X and gets got you one so this
is a very easy example it's clearly not
linearizable because the time rule means
that the only possible order is the
right of X with 1 the right of X is 2
the read of X with 1 so that has to be
the order and that order clearly
violates this is the only one order that
order clearly violates the second rule
about values that is you know the most
value written by the most recent right
in the owned one order that's possible
is not 1 it's 2 so this is clearly not
linearizable and the reason I'm bringing
it up is because this is the argument
that a linearizable system a strongly
consistent system cannot serve up stale
data right and you know the reason why
this might come up is again you know
maybe you have lots of replicas each you
know maybe haven't seen all the rights
or all the committed rights or something
so maybe there's some maybe all the
replicas have seen this right but only
some replicas have seen this right and
so if you ask a replica that's lagging
behind a little bit it's still gonna
have value 1 for X but nevertheless
clients should never be able to see this
old value in a linearizable system are
there no stale data allowed no still
reads
yeah if there's overlap in the interval
then there's then you know that you
could the system could legally execute
either of them in a real-time and I in
the interval so that's the sense in
which they could system gonna execute
them in either order now you know other
you know if it weren't for these two
reads the system would have you know
total freedom execute that writes in
either order but because we saw the two
reads we know that you know the only
legal order is two and then one yeah so
if the two reserva laughing then and
then any order then the reads could have
seen either in fact you know Toby saw
the two and the one words all from the
reads these doobies could have you know
the system until it committed to the
values for the read it still had freedom
to return them in either order
I'm using them as synonyms yeah yeah you
know for most people although possibly
not today's paper linearize ability is
is well defined and and people's
definitions really deviate very much
from this strong consistency though is
less I think there's less sort of
consensus about exactly what the
definition might be if you meant strong
consistency it's often men it's usually
men too in ways that are quite close to
this
like for example that oh the system
behaves the same way that a system with
only one copy of the data would behave
all right which is quite close to what
we're getting at with this definition
but yeah for you know it's reasonable to
assume that strong strong consistency is
the same as serializable okay so this is
not linearizable and the you know the
the lesson is weeds are not allowed to
return stale data only only fresh data
or you can only return the results of
the most recently completed right
okay I have a final final little example
so we have two clients one of them
submits a write to X with value three
and then write two acts with value 4 and
we have another client and you know at
this point in time the client issues a
read of X but and this is a question you
asked the the client doesn't get a
response right you know who knows like
it in the sort of actual implementation
may be the leader crashed at some point
maybe the his client to sent in the read
request so the leader maybe didn't get
it because the request was dropped or
maybe the leader got the request and
executed it but the response the network
dropped the response or maybe the leader
got it and started to process up and
then crash before finished processing
and or maybe did process it and crash
before saying the response who knows
when the clients point of view like sent
a request and never got a response so in
the interior machinery of the client for
most of the systems we're talking about
the client is going to resend the
request maybe do a different leader
maybe the same leader who knows what so
it sent the first question quest here
and maybe it sends the second request at
this point in time it times out you know
no response sends the second request at
this point and then finally gets a
response it turns out that and you're
going to implement this in lab 3 that a
reasonable way of servers dealing with
repeated requests is for their servers
to keep tables sort of indexed by some
kind of unique request number or
something from the clients in which the
servers remember oh I already saw that
request and executed it and this was the
response that I sent back because you
don't want to execute a request twice
you know if it's a for example if it's a
write request you don't want to execute
requests right so the server's have to
be able to filter out duplicate requests
and they have to be able to return the
reply to repeat the reply that the
originally
sent to that request which perhaps has
dropped by the network so that servers
remember the original pry and repeat it
in response to the resend and if you do
that which you will in lab 3 then if you
know since the server the leader could
have seen value 3 when it executed the
original read request from client to it
could return value 3 to the repeated
requests that was sent at this time and
completed at this time and so we have to
make a call on whether that is legal
right you could argue that oh gosh you
know the client we sent the request here
this was after the right of X 2 4
completed so Jesus what you really
should return for at this point instead
of 3 and this is like a little bit a
question of it's like a little bit up
the designer but if what you view is
going on is that the retransmissions are
a low-level concern that's you know part
of the RPC machinery or hidden in some
library or something and that from the
client applications point of view all
that happened was that it's sent a
request at this time and got a response
at this time and that's all that
happened from the clients point of view
then a value of 3 is totally legal here
because this request took a long time
it's completely concurrent with the
right not ordered in real time with the
right and therefore either the three or
the four is valid you know as if the
read requests that really executed here
in real time or or here in real time so
the larger lesson is if you have client
retransmissions the from the application
point of view if you're defining
linearize ability from the applications
point of view - even with
retransmissions the real time extent of
the requests like this is from the very
first transmission of the requests to
the final time at which the application
actually got the response maybe after
many reasons yes
you might rather you got fresh data than
stale data you know if I'm you know
supposing the request is what time it
what time is it that's a time server I
sent a request saying Oh what time is it
and it sends me a response you know yeah
if I send a request now and I don't get
the response until 2 minutes from now
dude some Network issue it may be that
the application would like prefer to see
we're gonna get the response it would
prefer to see a time that was close to
the time at which had actually got the
response rather than a time deep in the
past when it originally sent the request
now the fact is that if you you know if
you're using a system like this you have
to write applications that are tolerant
of these rules you're using a
linearizable system like these are the
rules and so you must write you know
correct applications must be tolerant of
you know if they send a request and they
get a response a while later they just
you know you can't are not allowed to
write the application as if oh gosh if I
get a response that means that the value
at the time I got the response was equal
to 3 that is not OK for applications to
think you know what that I have that
plays out for a given application
depends on what the application is doing
the reason I bring this up is because
it's a common question in 6 6 8 to 4 you
guys will implement the machinery by
which servers detect duplicates and
resend the previous answer that the
server originally sent and the question
will come up is it ok if you originally
saw the request here to return at this
point in time the response that you
would have sent back here if the network
hadn't dropped it and it's it's handy to
have a kind of way of reasoning I mean
one reason to have definitions like
linearize abilities to be able to reason
about questions like that right i'm
using using this scheme we can say well
it actually is okay by those rules
all right that's all i want to say about
linearize ability of any any lingering
questions yeah
well you know maybe I'm taking liberties
here but what's going on is that in real
time we have a read of - and a read of
one and the read of one really came
after in real time the read of two and
so must come must be in this order in
the final order that means there must
have been a right of - somewhere in here
it's our right with value one somewhere
in here that is after the read of - in
the final order right after the read of
- and before the read of one in that
order there must be a right with value
one there's only one right with a value
unavailable you know if there were more
than one we maybe could play games but
there's only one available so this right
must slip in here in the final order or
therefore I felt able to draw this arrow
and these arrows just capture the sort
of one by one implication of the rules
on what the order must look like yeah
all right yeah I mean any hour or X so
which sorry which which yeah his own rx1
he sees it before his own rx1 okay so
the via yep well we're not we're not
we're not really able to say which of
these two wheats came first so we can't
quite for all this error if we mean this
arrow to constrain the ultimate order
we're not you know the these two weeds
could come in either order so we're not
allowed to say this one came before that
one it could be there's a simpler cycle
actually then I've drawn so I mean it
may be because certainly the that the
damage is in these four items I agree
with that these two these four items
kind of are the main evidence that
something is wrong
now whether a cycle I'm not sure whether
there's a cycle that just involves that
there could be okay this is worth
thinking about cuz you know if I can't
think of anything better or I'll
certainly ask you a question about
linearizable histories on midterm
okay so today's paper today's paper
zookeeper and I mean part of the reason
we're even zookeeper paper is that it's
a successful real world system it's an
open source you know service that
actually a lot of people ron has been
incorporated into a lot of real world
software so there's a certain kind of
reality and success to it but you know
that makes attractive from the point of
view of kind of supporting the idea that
the zookeepers design might actually be
a reasonable design but the reason we're
interested in in it I'm interested in it
is for to somewhat more precise
technical points so why are we looking
at this paper so one of them is that in
contrast to raft like the raft you've
written and raft as that's defined it's
really a library you know you can use a
raft library as a part of some larger
replicated system but raft isn't like a
standalone service or something that you
can talk to it's you really have to
design your application to interact at
the raft library explicitly so you might
wonder it's an interesting question
whether some useful system sort of
standalone general-purpose system could
be defined that would be helpful for
people building separate distributed
systems like is there serve some service
that can bite off a significant portion
of why it's painful to build distributed
systems and sort of package it up in a
standalone service that you know anybody
can use so this is really the question
of what would an API look like for a
general purpose I'll call it I'm not
sure what the right name for things like
zookeeper is but you've got a general
purpose coordination service
and the other question the other
interesting aspect of zookeeper is that
when we build replicated systems and
zookeepers a replicated system because
among other things it's it's like a
fault-tolerant
general-purpose coordination service and
it gets fault tolerance like most
systems by replication that is there's a
bunch of you know maybe three or five or
seven or who knows what
zookeeper servers it takes money to buy
those servers right like a 7 server
zookeeper setup is 7 times expensive as
a sort of simple single server so it's
very tempting to ask if you buy 7
servers to run your replicated service
can you get 7 times the performance out
of your 7 servers right and you know how
could we possibly do that so the
question is you know we have n times as
many servers can that yield us n times
the performance so I'm gonna talk about
the second question first so from the
point of view this discussion about
performance I'm just going to view
zookeeper as just some service we don't
really care what the service is but
replicated with a raft like replication
system zookeeper actually runs on top of
this thing called Zab which for our
purposes
we'll just treat as being almost
identical to the raft and I'm just
worried about the performance of the
replication I'm not really worried about
what zookeepers specifically is up to so
the general picture is that you know we
have a bunch of clients maybe hundreds
maybe hundreds of clients and we have
just as in the lads we have a leader the
leader has a zookeeper layer that
clients talk to and then under the
zookeeper layer is the xab system that
manages replication then just like rafts
what was a a lot of what's that is doing
is maintaining a log that contains the
sequence of operations that clients have
sent in really very similar to raft may
have a bunch of these and each of them
has a log but it's a pending new request
that's a familiar set up so the
Clinton's in a request and the Zab layer
you know sends a copy of that request to
each of the replicas and the replicas
append this to their in-memory law I'd
probably persisted onto a disk so they
can get it back if they crash and
restart so the question is as we add
more servers you know we could have four
servers or five or seven or whatever
does the system get faster as we add
more more CPUs more horsepower to it do
you think your labs will get faster as
you have more replicas assuming they're
each replicas its own computer right so
that you really do get more CPU cycles
as you add more revenues
between all the
yeah yeah there's nothing about this
that makes it faster as you add more
servers right it's absolutely true like
as we have more servers you know the
leader is almost certainly a bottleneck
cuz the leader has to process every
request and it sends a copy of every
request to every other server as you add
more servers it just adds more work to
this bottleneck node right you're not
getting any benefit any performance
benefit out of the added servers because
they're not really doing anything
they're just all happily doing whatever
the leader tells them to do they're not
you know subtracting from the leaders
work and every single operation goes to
the leader so for here you know the
performance is you know inversely
proportional to the number of servers
that you add you add more servers this
almost certainly gets lower because the
leader just has more work so in this
system we have the problem that more
servers makes the system slower that's
too bad you know these servers cost a
couple thousand bucks each and you would
hope that you could use them to get
better performance yeah
okay so the question is what if the
requests may be from different clients
or successive requests and same client
or something what if the requests apply
two totally different parts of the state
so you know in a key value store maybe
one of them is a put on X and the other
was a put on Y like nothing to do with
each other you know can we take
advantage of that and the answer that is
absolutely now not in this framework
though or it's the center which we can
take advantage of it it's very limited
in this framework it could be well at a
high level the leader the requests all
still go through the leader and the
leader still has to send it out to all
the replicas and the more replicas there
are the more messages the leader has to
send so at a high level it's not likely
to this sort of commutative or community
of requests is not likely to help this
situation is a fantastic thought to keep
in mind though because it'll absolutely
come up in other systems and people will
be able to take advantage of it in other
systems okay so so there's a little bit
disappointing facts with server hardware
wasn't helping performance so a very
sort of obvious maybe the simplest way
that you might be able to harness these
other servers is build a system in which
ya write requests all have to go through
the leader but in the real world a huge
number of workloads are read heavy that
is there's many more reads like when you
look at web pages you know it's all
about reading data to produce the web
page and generally there are very
relatively few rights and that's true of
a lot of systems so maybe we'll send
rights to the leader but send weeds just
to one of the replicas right just pick
one of the replicas and if you have a
read-only request like a get in lab 3
just send it to one of the replicas and
not to the leader now if we do that we
haven't helped rights much although
we've gotten a lot of read workload off
the leader so maybe that helps but we
absolutely have made tremendous progress
with reads because now the more servers
we add the more clients we can support
right because we're just splitting the
client lead work
across the different replicas so the
question is if we have clients send
directly to the replicas are we going to
be happy
yeah so up-to-date does the right is the
right word in a raft like system which
zookeeper is if a client sends a request
to a random replica you know sure the
replica you know has a copy the log in
it you know it's been executing along
with the leader and you know for lab 3
it's got this key value table and you
know you do a get for key X and it's
gonna have some four key exodus table
and it can reply to you so sort of
functionally the replicas got all the
pieces it needs to respond to client to
read requests from clients the
difficulty is that there's no reason to
believe that anyone replicas other than
the leader is up to date because well
there's a bunch of reasons why why
replicas may not be up to date one of
them is that they may not be in the
majority that the leader was waiting for
you think about what raft is doing the
leader is only obliged to wait for
responses to its append entries from a
majority of the followers and then it
can commit the operation and go on to
the next operation so if this replica
wasn't in the majority it may never have
seen a riot it may be the network
dropped it and never got it and so yeah
you know the leader and you know a
majority of the servers have seen the
first three requests but you know this
server only saw the first two it's
missing B so read to be a read of you
know what should be there I'll just be
totally get a stale value from this one
even if this replica actually saw this
new log entry it might be missing the
commit command you know this zookeepers
app as much the same as raft it first
sends out a log entry and then when the
leader gets a majority of positive
replies the leader sends out a
notification saying yeah I'm gonna
committing that log entry I may not have
gotten the commit and the sort of worst
case version of this although its
equivalent to what I already said is
that for all this client for all client
to knows this replica may be partitioned
from the leader or may just absolutely
not be in contact with leader at all and
you know the follower doesn't really
have a way of knowing
that actually it's just been cut off a
moment ago from the leader and just not
getting anything so you know without
some further cleverness if we want to
build a linearizable system we can't
play this game of sending the attractive
it as it is for performance we can't
play this game at replicas sending a
read request to the replicas and you
shouldn't do it for lab 3 either because
that 3 is also supposed to be
linearizable it's any any questions
about why linearize ability forbids us
from having replicas serve clients ok
you know that the proof is the I lost it
now but the proof was that simple
reading you know right one right to read
one example I put on the board earlier
you not a lot just you know this is not
allowed to serve stale data in the
linear linearizable system ok so how
does how does ooh keep our deal with
this zookeeper actually does you can
tell from table two you look in Table
two zookeepers read performance goes up
dramatically as you add more servers so
clearly zookeepers playing some game
here which allows must be allowing it to
return read only to serve read only
requests from the additional servers the
replicas so how does ooh keeper make
this safe
that's right I mean in fact it's almost
not allowed to say it does need the
written latest yeah the way zookeeper
skins this cat is that it's not
linearizable right they just like to
find away this problem and say well
we're not gonna be we're not going to
provide linearizable reads and so
therefore you don't are not obliged
you know zookeepers not obliged to
provide fresh data to reads it's allowed
by its rules of consistency which are
not linearizable to produce stale data
for Wheaton's so it's sort of solved
this technical problem with a kind of
definitional wave of the wand by saying
well we never owed you them linearizable
it'll be in the first place so it's not
a bug if you don't provide it and that's
actually a pretty classic way to
approach this to approach the sort of
tension between performance and strict
and strong consistency is to just not
provide strong consistency nevertheless
we have to keep in the back of our minds
question of if the system doesn't
provide linearize ability is it still
going to be useful right and you do a
read and you just don't get the current
answer or current correct answer the
most latest data like why do we believe
that that's gonna produce a useful
system and so let me talk about that so
first of all any questions about about
the basic problem zookeeper really does
allow client to send read-only requests
to any replica and the replica responds
out of its current state and that
replicate may be lagging it's log may
not have the very latest log entries and
so it may return stale data even though
there's a more recent committed value
okay so what are we left with
zookeeper does actually have some it
does have a set of consistency
guarantees so to help people who write
zookeeper based applications reason
about what their applications what's
actually going to happen when they run
them so
and these guarantees have to do with
ordering as indeed linearise ability
does so zookeeper does have two main
guarantees that they state and this is
section 2.3 one of them is it says that
rights rights or linearizable now you
know there are notion of linearizable
isn't not quite the same in mine maybe
because they're talking about rights no
beads what they really mean here is that
the system behaves as if even though
clients might submit rights concurrently
nevertheless the system behaves as if it
executes the rights one at a time in
some order and indeed obeys real-time
ordering of right so if one right has
seen to have completed before another
right has issued then do keeper will
indeed act as if it executed the second
right after the first right so it's
rights but not reads are linearizable
and zookeeper isn't a strict readwrite
system there are actually rights that
imply reads also and for those sort of
mixed rights those those you know any
any operation that modifies the state is
linearizable with respect to all other
operations that modify the state the
other guarantee of gives is that any
given client its operations executes in
the order specified by the client
they call that FIFO client order
and what this means is that if a
particular client issues a right and
then a read and then a read and a right
or whatever that first of all the rights
from that sequence fit in in the client
specified order in the overall order of
all clients rights so if a client says
do this right then that right and the
third right in the final order of rights
will see the clients rates occur in the
order of the client specified so for
rights this is our client specified
order and this is particularly you know
this is a issue with the system because
clients are allowed to launch
asynchronous right requests that is a
client can fire off a whole sequence of
rights to the leader to the zookeeper
leader without waiting for any of them
to complete and in order resume the
paper doesn't exactly say this but
presumably in order for the leader to
actually be able to execute the clients
rights in the client specified order
we're imagining I'm imagining that the
client actually stamps its write
requests with numbers and saying you
know I'll do this one first this one
second this one third and the zookeeper
leader obeys that ordering right so this
is particularly interesting due to these
asynchronous write requests and for
reads this is a little more complicated
the reasons I said before don't go
through the writes all go through the
leader the reads just go to some
replicas and so all they see is the
stuff that happens to have made it to
that replicas log the way we're supposed
to think about the FIFO client order for
reads is that if the client issues a
sequence of reads again in some order
the client reads one thing and then
another thing and then a third thing
that relative to the log on the replicas
talking to those clients reads each have
to occur at some particular point in the
log or they need to sort of observe the
state as it as the state existed at a
particular point
the log and furthermore that the
successive reads have to observe points
that don't go backwards that is if a
client issues one read and then another
read and the first read executes at this
point in the log the second read is that
you know allowed to execute it the same
or later points in the log but not
allowed to see a previous state by issue
one read and then another read the
second read has to see a state that's at
least as up-to-date as the first state
and that's a significant fact in that
we're gonna harness when we're reasoning
about how to write correct zookeeper
applications and where this is
especially exciting is that if the
client is talking to one replica for a
while and it issues some reads issue to
read here and then I read there if this
replica fails and the client needs to
start sending its read to another
replica that guaranteed this FIFO client
or a guarantee still holds if the client
switches to a new replica and so that
means that if you know before a crash
the client did a read that sort of saw
state as of this point in the log that
means when the clients wishes to the new
replicas if it issues another read you
know it's its previous read executed
here
if a client issues another read that
read has to execute at this point or
later even though it's switched replicas
and you know the way this works is that
each of these log entries is tagged by
the leader tags it with a Z X ID which
is basically just a entry number
whenever a replica responds to a client
read request it you know executed the
request at a particular point and the
replica responds with the Z X ID of the
immediately preceding log entry back to
the client the client remembers this was
the exid of the most recent data you
know is the highest z x idea i've ever
seen and when the client sends a request
to the same or a different replica it
accompanies their request with that
highest CX ID has ever seen and that
tells this other replica aha you know i
need to respond to that request with
data that's at least relative to this
point in a log
and that's interesting if this you know
this replicas not up this second replica
is even less up to date yes was then
received any of these but it receives a
request from a client the client says oh
gosh the last read I did executed this
spot in the log and some other replica
this replica needs to wait until it's
gotten the entire log up to this point
before it's allowed to respond to the
client and I'm not sure exactly how that
works but either the replicas just
delays responding to the read or maybe
it rejects the read and says look I just
don't know the information talk to
somebody else or talk to me later
where's eventually the you know this
replica will catch up if it's connected
to the leader and then you won't be able
to respond
okay so reads are ordered they only go
forward in time or only go forward in
sort of log order and a further thing
which I believe is true about reason
rights is that reads and writes the FIFO
client order applies to all of a clients
all of a single clients requests so if I
do a write from a client and I send a
write to the leader it takes time before
that write is sent out committed
whatever so I may send it right to the
leader the leader hasn't processed it or
committed it yet and then I send a read
to a replica the read may have to stall
you know in order to guarantee FIFO
client order the read and they have to
stall until this client has actually
seen and executed the previous the
client's previous write operation so
that's a consequence of this type of
client order is that a reason rights are
in the same order and you know the way
the most obvious way to see this is if a
client writes a particular piece of data
you know sends a write to the leader and
then immediately does a read of the same
piece of data and sends that read to a
replica boy it better see its own
written value right if I write something
to have value 17 and then I do a read
and it doesn't have value 17 then that's
just bizarre and it's evidence that gosh
the system was not executing my requests
in order because then it would have
executed the write and then before the
read so there must be some funny
business with the replicas stalling
the client must when it sends a read and
say look you know I the last write
request I sent a leader with ZX ID
something in this replica has to wait
till it sees that I'm the leader yes
oh absolutely so I think what you're
observing is that a read from a replica
may not see the latest data so the
leader may have sent out C to a majority
of replicas and committed it and the
majority may have executed it but if our
replica that we're talking wasn't in
that majority maybe this replica doesn't
have the latest data and that just is
the way zoo keeper works and so it does
not guarantee that we'd see the latest
data so if there there is a guarantee
about readwrite ordering but it's only
per client so if I send a write in and
then I read that data the system
guarantees that my bead observes my
right if you send a right in and then I
read the data that you wrote this isn't
does not guarantee that I see your right
and that's and you know that's like the
foundation of how they get speed up for
reads proportional to the number of
replicas
but I would say the system isn't
linearizable and and but it is not that
it has no properties then the rights are
certainly many all right all rights from
all clients form some one at a time
sequence so that's a sense in which the
rights all rights are the knee risible
and each individual clients operations
may be this means linearizable also it
may you know this this probably means
that each individual clients operations
are linearize well though I'm not quite
sure you know I'm actually not sure how
it works but that's a reasonable
supposition then when I send in an
asynchronous right the system doesn't
execute it yet but it does reply to me
saying yeah you know I got your right
and here's this yaks ID that it will
have if it's committed I just like start
return so that's a reasonable theory I
don't actually know how it does it and
then the client if it doesn't read needs
to tell the replicas look you know
that's right I did you know if I do a
read of the data is of the operation
okay so if you send a read to a replica
the replicas in return you that you know
really it's a read from this table is
what your no way notionally what the
client thinks it's doing so you client
says all I want to read this row from
this table the server this replica sends
back its current value for that table
plus the GX ID of the last operation
that updated that table
yeah so there's so actually I'm I'm not
prepared to so the the two things that
would make sense and I think either of
them would be okay is the server could
track this yet for every table row the
ZX ID of the last right operation that
touched it or it could just to all read
requests returned the ZX ID as a last
committed operation in its log
regardless of whether that was the last
operation of touch that row because all
we need to do is make sure that client
requests move forward in the order so we
just need something to return something
that's greater than or equal to the
right that last touched the data that
the client read all right so these are
the guarantees so you know we still left
with a question of whether it's possible
to do reasonable programming with this
set of guarantees and the answer is well
this you know at a high level this is
not quite as good as linearizable it's a
little bit harder to reason about and
there's sort of more gotchas like reads
can return stale data just can't happen
in a linearizable system but it's
nevertheless good enough to do to make
it pretty straightforward to reason
about a lot of things you might want to
do with zookeeper so there's a so I'm
gonna try to construct an argument maybe
by example of why this is not such a bad
programming model one reason by the way
is that there's an out there's this
operation called sink which is
essentially a write operation and if a
client you know supposing I know that
you recently wrote something you being a
different client and I want to read what
you wrote so I actually want fresh data
I can send in one of these sink
operations which is effectively well the
sync operation makes its way through the
system as if it were a write and you
know finally showing up in the logs of
the replicas that really at least the
replicas that I'm talking to and then I
can come back and do a read and you know
I can I can tell the replica basically
don't serve this read until you've seen
my last sink and that actually falls out
naturally from fifl client order if we
if we countersink as a right then five-o
client order says reads are required to
see state you know there's as least as
up to date is the last right from that
client and so if I send in a sink and
then I do read I'm the the system is
obliged to give me data that's visas up
to date as where my sink fell in the log
order anyway if I need to read
up-to-date data send in a sink then do a
read and the read is guaranteed to see
data as of the time the same was entered
into the log so reasonably fresh so
that's one out but it's an expensive one
because you now we converted a cheap
read into the sink operation which
burned up time on the leader so it's a
no-no if you don't have to do but here's
a couple of examples of scenarios that
the paper talks about that the reasoning
about them is simplified or reasonably
simple given the rules that are here so
first I want to talk about the trick in
section 2.3 of with the ready file where
we assume there's some master and the
Masters maintaining a configuration in
zookeeper which is a bunch of files and
zookeeper that describe you know
something about our distributed system
like the IP addresses of all the workers
or who the master is or something so we
the master who's updating this
configuration and maybe a bunch of
readers that need to read the current
configuration and need to see it every
time it changes and so the question is
you know can we construct something that
even though updating the configure even
though the configuration is split across
many files in zookeeper we can have the
effect of an atomic update so that
workers don't see workers that look at
the configuration don't see a sort of
partially updated configuration but only
a completely updated that's a classic
kind of thing that this configuration
management that zookeeper people using
zookeeper for so you know looking at the
so we're copying what section 2.3
describes this will say the master is
doing a bunch of rites to update the
configuration and here's the order that
the master for our distributed system
does the rites
first we're assuming there's some ready
file a file named ready and if they're
ready file exists then the configuration
is we're allowed to read the
configuration if they're ready files
missing that means the configuration is
being updated and we shouldn't look at
it so if the master is gonna update the
configuration file the very first thing
it does is delete the ready file then it
writes the various files very zookeeper
files that hold the data for the
configuration might be a lot of files
nose and then when it's completely
updated all the files that make up the
configuration then it creates again
that's ready file
alright so so far the semantics are
extremely straightforward this is just
rights there's only rights here no reads
rights are guaranteed to execute in
linear order and I guess now we have to
appeal the fifl client order if the
master sort of tags these as oh you know
I want my rights to occur in this order
then the reader is obliged to enter them
into the replicated log in that order
and so though you know the replicas were
all dutifully execute these one at a
time they'll all delete the ready file
then apply this right in that right and
then create the ready file again so
these are rights the orders
straightforward for the reads though
it's it's maybe a little bit maybe a
little more thinking as required
supposing we have some worker that needs
to read the current configuration we're
going to assume that this worker first
checks to see whether the ready file
exists it doesn't exist it's gonna you
know sleep and try again so let's assume
it does exist let's assume we assume
that the worker checks to see
if the ready file exists after it's
recreated and so you know what this
means now these are all right requests
sent to the leader this is a read
request that's just centrally whatever
replica the clients talking to and then
if it exists you know it's gonna read f1
and B that - the interesting thing that
FIFO client order guarantees here is
that if this returned true that is if
the replica the client was talking to
said yes that file exists then you know
as were as that what that means is that
at least with this setup is that as that
replica that that replica had actually
seen the recreate of the ready file
right in order for this exist to see to
see the ready file exists and because
successive read operations are required
to march along only forwards in the long
and never backwards that means that you
know if the replicas the client was
talking to if it's log actually
contained and then it executes this
creative the ready file that means that
subsequent client reads must move only
forward in the sequence of rights you
know that the leader put into the log so
if we saw this ready that means that the
read occurs that the replica excuse to
read down here somewhere after the right
that created the ready and that means
that the reads are guaranteed to observe
the effects of these rights so we do
actually get some benefit here some
reasoning benefit from the fact that
even though it's not fully linearizable
the rights are linearizable and the
reads have to read sort of monotonically
move forward in time to the log yes
[Music]
yeah so that's a great question so your
question is well in all this client
knows you know if this is the real
scenario that the creators entered in
the log and then the read arrives at the
replica after that replica executed this
creepy ready then everything's
straightforward but there's other
possibilities for how this stuff was
interleaved
so let's look at a much more troubling
scenario so the scenario you brought up
which I happen to be prepared to talk
about is that yeah you know the the
master at some point executed to a
delete of ready or you know way back in
time some previous master this master
created the ready file
you know after it finished updating the
state I say ready for I existed for a
while then some new master or this
master needs to change the
configurations release the ready file
you know it doesn't right right and
what's really troubling is that the
client that needs to read this
configuration might have called exists
to see whether the ready file exists at
this time all right and you know at this
point in time yeah sure the ready file
exists then time passes and the client
issues the reads for the maybe the
client reads the first file that makes
up the configuration but maybe it you
know and then it reads the second file
maybe this file this read comes totally
after the master has been changing the
configurations so now this reader has
read this damaged mix of f1 from the old
configuration and f2 from the new
configuration there's no reason to
believe that that's going to contain
anything other than broken information
so so this first scenario was great the
scenario is a disaster and so now we're
starting to get into
of like serious challenges which a
carefully designed API for coordination
between machines in a distributed system
might actually help us solve right
because like for lab 3 you know you're
gonna build a put get system and a
simple lab 3 style put guessed system
you know it would run into this problem
too and just does not have any tools to
deal with it
but the zookeeper API actually is more
clever than this and it can cope with it
and so what actually happens the way you
would actually use ooh keeper is that
when the client sent in this exists
request to ask does this file exist and
would say not only does this file exist
but it would say you know tell me if it
exists even set a watch on that file
which means if the files ever deleted or
if it doesn't exist if it's ever created
but in this case if it if it is ever
deleted please send me a notification
and furthermore the notifications that
zookeeper sends you know it's a the
reader here it's only talking to some
replicas this is all the replicas doing
these things for it the replica
guarantees to send a notification for
some change to this ready file at the
correct point relative to the responses
to the clients reads and so what that
means so you know because that the the
implication of that is that in this
scenario in which you know these these
rights sort of fit in here in real time
the guarantee is that if you ask for a
watch on something and then you issue
some reads if that replica you're
talking to execute something that should
trigger the watch in during your
sequence of reads then the replica
guarantees to deliver the notification
about the watch before it responds to
any read that came that you know saw the
log after the point
of the OP where the operation that
triggered the watch notification
executed and so this is the log on the
replica and so you know if the so that
you know the FIFO client ordering will
say you know each client requests must
fit somewhere into the log apparently
these fit in here in the log what we're
worried about is that this read occurs
here in the log but we set up this watch
and the guarantee is that will receive
the note if if somebody deletes this
file and we can notified then that
notification will will appear at the
client before a read that yields
anything subsequently in the log will
get the notification before we get the
results of any read that's that saw
something in log after the operation
that produced the notification so what
this means that the delete ready is
gonna since we have a watch on the ready
file that elite ready is going to
generate a notification and that
notification is guaranteed to be
delivered before the read result of f2
if f2 was gonna see this second right
and that means that before the reading
client has finished the sequence in
which it looks at the configuration it's
guaranteed to see the watch notification
before it sees the results of any write
that happened after this delete that
triggered the notification
who generates the watch as well the
replica let's say the client is talking
to this replica and it sends in the
exists request the exist room has a read
only request it sends with his replica
the replica is being painting on the
side a table of watches saying oh you
know such-and-such a client asked for a
watch on this file and furthermore the
watch was established at a particular Z
X ID that is did a read that client did
a read with the replica executed the
read at this point in the log and return
results are relative to this point in
the log members owe that watch is
relative to that point in the log and
then if a delete comes in you know for
every operation that there s Q so it
looks in this little table it says aha
you know the a there was a watch on that
file and maybe it's indexed by hash of
filename or something
okay so the question is oh yeah this
this replica has to have a watch table
you know if the replica crashes and the
client is officially different replica
you know what about the watch table
right it's already established these
watch and the answer to that is that no
the rep your replica crashes the new
replica you switch to won't have the
watch table and but the client gets a
notification at the appropriate point in
in the stream of responses it gets back
saying oops your replica you were
talking to you crashed and so the client
then knows it has to completely reset up
everything and so tucked away in in the
examples are missing event handlers to
say oh gosh you know we need to go back
and we establish everything if we get a
notification that our replicas crashed
all right I'll continuous